your wants happen Louie no I don't want
anything we shouldn't be here you should
call mom tell her we're coming back
right now oh yeah god damn baby you're a
baby
welcome a this is not happening I'm
going with junior we all come from
somewhere from someone who nurtures us
protects us and teaches us some are
better at it than others
[Music]
you know from the colleges are so
bastards
he is Louie Anderson
this story takes place in my teeny it's
a big 64 way back in the wayback machine
Khrushchev was our Putin Johnson was our
trump cars were like boats kids were fat
and dads were veterans and they drank
sometimes we were poor 11 kids at 11
kids of my family I was tenth I just
slid out I was I was home before my mom
from the hospital I defend for myself as
winter in Minnesota Saint Paul Minnesota
11:20 to the Avenue that's where you
remember where you live when you're a
kid that's no numbers since then can I
remember so it's like a winter day and
but not bad but not freezing but not
livable
you know me and my brother Tommy he was
two years younger than me and we were
the last two kids I was 10 he was 11 we
weren't expected or planned for or we
were just oh my god we have two more my
parents were both older and I I just
remember it well we live in the projects
but it didn't feel bad living in the
projects then we had lawns there were
flowers
my dad's lawn because he was notorious
people were terrified of my dad so he
just had to put a string and sticks
around his lawn and nobody ever kicked
it over and I just went oh my god he's a
monster to them too sometimes I'd kick
it over and you go what doubt anyway so
my dad goes hey kids that's how my dad
talk hey hey guys and that was a
talkback Hey oh yeah I guess hey you
wanna go to Joe's Joe's was a gas
station that sold the cheapest gas I
don't know where he was getting at but
anyways my dad goes oh I go to Joe's I
need to get some gas and get some bulk
oil now you gotta be old to north bulk
oil is it's the oil that already has
been used and they run it through a like
a strainer and then you can purchase it
for ten cents a quart and my dad knew a
value when he saw it so we had a car
that burned a lot of oil so he would go
but he said you want to go I go no I
don't want to go and my brother I go
Tommy you don't want to go he goes I
want to go you don't want to go you're
not going
shut up
lil Iran sugar would just go up there no
big deal ha
and I know I know what my dad's up to
cuz he can't get out of the house unless
he brings the kids cuz otherwise he'll
drink and that my mom knows that she
knows that she goes you're just gonna go
drink he goes I'll bring the kids and I
wanted to go that won't stop him
who's gonna drink and so we get up there
it's starting to snow we got a big
Bonneville station wagon which is
gigantic and we get the bulk oil you
guys hungry for yeah i canti or soda or
something no to get home I was that kid
mom's worried about us I'm sure by now
[Music]
she said you're a derelict oh is that so
Louie well have you ever been to war
Louie I'm 11 always some accessory
because why don't we go over the Moose
Lodge here do you know Moose Lodge is
like a private club sort of but anyone
can come in at certain hours so we go in
the Moose Lodge there no moose except
one on the wall that did not look well
and we sit at the bar you know and I'm
at I'm very against this that's the kid
I was I'm sitting there I'm in between
my dad and my brother you wants out in
Louie no I don't want anything we
shouldn't be here we should call mom
tell her we're coming back right now
hiya goddamn baby you're a baby so
you're sharing a want root beer I don't
want nothing with beer enough it's the
kind of kid I was just a little I don't
know bitch I guess in some way I don't
mean that in a female way but I can say
it now because I play a woman on TVs I
go oh no I don't know anything and my
dad hey Tommy you want some he doesn't
want anything we're in a pact he's not
gonna go along with it
hey shirt and tell me a car yeah I want
something and he keeps my dad keeps and
he's getting a shot and a beer each time
he drinks his beer and he goes back away
so I go home I never realized that he
had that ability to go that far back it
must have been a war thing I can't go I
gotta so they can't shoot this stay down
so he's drinking the shots he owes you
sure you don't want something Louie what
about our Orange Crush I know
hey how about a pickled egg Oh maybe
never
who wants a pickled egg who's eating the
pickled egg who's at the barn going God
is that a pickled egg in the jar the one
that guy just stuck his hand in to get a
pickled egg on oh god damn it I want a
pickled egg could I just get a pickled
egg you have any bread I could put the
pickle a guard on and on finally he's
got Tommy it won't be long now
couple more he's going off the stool I'm
pretty sure boom he goes off this duel
the guy goes that's it like the guy who
gave up all the booze that's at
all right I need you guys out of here
what are we gonna go
he is so plastered and now if it's your
father
you humiliated you're upset but there's
a lot of humor in my family so I'm
laughing and that sick laugh thing like
why is it cause that a prick so here I
am now my dad was very funny in because
I'm already I can drive I drove a tank I
don't trust you I got a little I know
Dewey Dewey
Louie Louie that's right
dad's would they ride that would he get
drunk he should fall over but he had a
gyroscope and so somehow kept him up he
just a look at ya I'm alright no you're
not
we get in the car I'm telling you the
snow's a foot foot now he gets in the
driver's seat I get in the middle Tommy
sits there you go you're ready to go
home
all ready to go dad I got that now we're
going down I go by my grade school Ames
great I go dad won't you just let me out
just say it's all morning oh just like
Tommy and I out here he does good now we
got it Lily no what are you worried
about we're all over the road we're
going there's no other car out there
it's beautifully it's really like I keep
going god this is really beautiful
but I'm in trouble I'm 11 I don't have a
learner's permit I'm steering the car
we're going down the thing we got three
roads to get by we go by the witch's
haunted house that we used to walk by in
school you always have some kind of
weird thing that's where the witches are
that we have a little brother you need
that they're gonna get you anyway Edie
and we're going down the hill and we
have a pretty steep hill so we turn and
now we're almost home who's that one
more turn 11:22 right up there I can I
can't see it
and then my dad all of a sudden he just
the car stops and he just passes out I
go oh my god the windshield wipers are
going there's only this much open to see
cuz only where my dad's alcohol breath
is clearing the window and I'm going I
guess I could walk from here but I hate
to walk even as a kid I go oh could you
pick me up
we'll get to people then anyway and so
anyways my dad oh I heard it what you
know I'm back oh thank you thanks for
the coffee Oh dad so he wakes I go okay
we're almost home out step on the break
and then I'll guide the car home just
take it easy he hits the gas all the way
down we fly back catch me if I do
happened uh it only hurt at first and I
flew back and my dad gun the car it had
never gone so fast ever we're at least
going 50 miles an hour and we lived 11
22 then right across the street was the
Big Woods that we had BB gun flights in
and boom we hit the curb the car went up
I know
honestly I just went oh my god hey what
what I think I said sure now it's we're
low if her dad said that we land it and
that all the snow and it was like we're
I go there's like a snow globe we we are
shake somebody's shaking us
and this was a big hill that I had to
get up now we were down in the gold and
we had ice that for a week so we could
slide on cardboard that's what we slid
on but we had ice that we take buckets
of water no one will ever get up this so
fat Louie is going there we go I get up
to it I get about halfway up and I go ah
there's my grab of loser right there
else and I just go on my back and go
down I did it like three or four times
guy just go I'm just gonna enjoy this
and then finally I got up to the very
top and there was a road that's right
there's my house and the neighbor came
by hey are you guys okay
everything's perfect we got it go ahead
you're sure you don't need any help with
me they help that was by rolling the
family deflect deflect deflect
where do they help thunder control
someone shout out tires out I didn't
want those people to help because it's a
family thing in families you're sure of
dad at your situation it's your family
you wit it to the woods
it's not even explainable really it's
just I finally get up and across the
street and I go in the house and my
brother Rogers there what's going on dad
drove into the woods uh-huh for God's
sakes everybody has that voice in our
family so even mom oh my god
my mom was really mad she was she just
went mm-hmm he said that my brother go
get him go get him
Tommy's in there I told to stay I said
don't get out Tommy just stay with that
and then he went again he was able to
drive the car off my dad they brought my
dad in drunk so drunk sat in the chair I
was sitting there because when you're 11
you have to think about supper you can't
really contemplate it very well you just
go huh starving should I eat the egg my
dad rustles out of his deep do you know
drunken stupor
yeah he's alive e labs my brother Raj is
standing right next to nose hey buddy
hey you want to go to Joe's with me hey
get some bulk oil I never got to go with
my dad again on any trip alone I hope
you enjoyed that thank you so much
[Applause]